I like wouldn't mess with me if I saw me
on the street because it looks like I
can kick some ass I'm what people call
an ABC an American born Chinese my mom
is from Taiwan and my dad's from Hong
Kong my family's from China Vietnam my
parents were from Hong Kong this is the
first time I'll be wearing Chinese
traditional clothing I grew up seeing
like Jet Li and Jackie Chan wearing
these clothes in movies I don't like to
admit it but I think there is this
pressure on Asian Americans to blend in
I feel like I'm still trying to learn to
accept myself in America I feel like
it's gonna emphasize my chineseness and
Asian is even more I look like I'm from
the past getting looks and getting
questions is something that I'm not
looking forward to this is something my
grandpa would go to sleep in I'm
expecting to have a lot of fun to be
honest if I do see people wearing this
it's definitely on some kind of holiday
like Chinese New Year I can't stop with
hemp oh this is crazy
my mom would be very happy to see me in
these clothes right now I'm about to go
out into the outside world and we're
about to get some dim sum you look so
pretty
so many people actually are
complimenting me on this I don't know if
they're just trying to be nice it
actually feels really nice though with
like the wind and the air and just
walking down the street and there's also
someone staring from a car like they
were like what smiling there was one guy
I noticed who's taking a lot of pictures
right there I don't know if you'd see
him it was crazy
I'm about to figure my girlfriend for
lunch she was pretty surprised she
thought it was a prank I think okay um
to flashy Oh what do you think very very
sex I have to hold this up and then I
also have to get the sleeve when I wipe
I don't get [ __ ] on my outfit these are
my co-workers give you your first
impression and now all of a sudden you
were behind me so I was like oh my god
are you a ninja and I don't think of it
because you're wearing the red but maybe
that was five I made this absurd comment
and then we just called her out on it
good luck more Asian you look a lot more
Asian good I think it's great I'm super
into it actually like you're going to an
event vibe like fancy event you might
look like a man from the 60s going to
bed Hugh Hefner so Jessica there's
something about like sweating a little
bit in sylphid is still so unwholesome
to me
I was interesting because it started a
dialogue about where you come from and
your parents and your lineage and stuff
so I thought it was interesting I'm
proud to be Asian but it's just
exhausting having to wear my identity on
my sleeve like this when I first put on
the outfit and I was driving I felt like
a lot of people were staring at me I
just felt self-conscious in a way it
made me base and address my Asian this
head-on like in a very physical way I
think people's positive reactions really
validated me wearing the outfit and it
helped my confidence someone asked me Oh
does everybody in China wear stuff like
this it made me realize that not
everybody understands like how Asia
works the other Asian people that saw me
really lit up and was like hey there's
an Asian person representing it's really
important to think about your place as
an Asian American by the end of it I
felt kind of cool and I felt proud to be
wearing it it was a really fun
experience I think I would definitely do
it again just wear whatever you want as
long as you're like holding yourself and
being
it's all good remember when your mom
dressed huge city in China boss yeah I
just said hair photo just gonna love it